do you have
advice for young folks today you've had
like an incredible
dark journey
and a successful one a loving one
and one of the most successful
artists in the world
is there advice you can give to young
people today that would like to find
themselves to that way especially if
they're struggling i thought you said
device at first and i was like honestly
i feel like that device is not helping
like maybe everybody should get away
throw away their devices um advice
um
i would just say like what i emphasize
to my kids is
i really really want my kids to just
learn to love themself
it's it's easier said than done
it's really easy to pick on yourself in
life
it's really easy to look in the mirror
and wish you looked different
wish you were more successful like that
person over there
wish that
you know wish a lot of things
and people that i see that really
succeed at life
really succeed truly and that doesn't
mean they're making money necessarily or
they're succeeding and you know they're
talking to a lot of people like their
success success to me is like
happy
and
real they have real self-love you meet
you know when you meet someone you meet
rick for instance you meet rick rubin
rick has a calmness about him and it's
funny because everybody sees him as this
like zen master like
rick is just
a really
loving person who also loves himself and
has self-confidence because you just see
it and it resonates and that's why he
draws people and that's why he's so
great in the studio because you know his
intentions always as an artist when a
producer comes in you're like whoa whoa
whoa what are your intentions what are
you trying to do are you trying to get a
hit out of me for the label or you're
trying to make me something are you
trying to like make me this so you can
prove this about yourself like there's a
lot in that dynamic and the reason that
rick is so good is because
you know his intentions
and his intentions come because rick has
that self-love so for me
find the things about yourself because
they're there
that you love
and really focus in on them
and it's not selfish like i feel like i
was brought up in a family too where it
was like
never look inward like be selfless like
serve serve serve which by the way i'm
is a true principle of life i think you
love yourself more when you serve more i
think that's
really evident in life but also spend
time doing the things that make you
happy take time every day to go on that
walk that you need to go on listen to
that book tape that you need to listen
to like for me that's something i need i
know if i do that i'm going to be a
better dad because i did i did i gave
myself some some love back in life
and uh and i just forgive yourself i
think forgive yourself because everybody
messes up everybody hurts others
everybody says unkind words at times
everybody
everybody fails all the time and if you
think that you're gonna not
you're wrong and you're eventually going
to and you're either going to punish
yourself for it every day and be a
lesser version of what you could be
or you're going to forgive yourself for
it
and if you've learned that that's not
something you want then try not to do it
again if you do it again and you're
probably going to do it again whatever
that is you're gonna you're gonna gossip
about that person you're gonna feel bad
because then you gossiped about someone
like is there something you could say in
terms of self-love
is there a role for being critical and
just like that that those demons of like
self-criticism do you need a little bit
of that tom waits talks about i like my
town with a little drop of poison right
you need a little poison
or or is it is that silly or romantic no
i mean it's listen look it's my my
biggest thing in life this
has been like the thing that i've worked
on the hardest for the last few years
is to not be overly critical
um
[Music]
and
to let go of control
i i think um
it's really easy to kill an artist
it's really easy to kill an artist like
if my dad would have sat down with me
that day
and even if he would have just sat down
and been like
good job son okay it's not silly right
like i don't i didn't not everybody has
a dad who's gonna ever do something or
put in the time or whatever
but
that would that might have altered
everything for me yeah like my dad
taking the extra time to be to just give
me a thoughtful response opposed to kids
know kids know when you're when you're
just like trying to get out of the room
or whatever i knew he wasn't
and that did a lot so yeah
but is that is that a huge
is not what makes the artist it's the
fragility of it
that
like uh would you have it any other way
no no i i agree with you i think that
that's what
that uh
that's the beauty of art but i think
also on the same token it's like
i went to i went to music cares recently
which is a charity for musicians that
are down on their luck that maybe were
successful at one point or i've never
been successful and they can't pay the
bills and this charity
contributes money to these artists
aspiring artists or artists who've had
drug issues and like there's a lot that
they do but and there was a statistic
that they told it was staggering to me
which is i think it was 75 percent
of artists musicians
say they struggle with severe depression
that's really high i don't know what the
national average is
but i would guess that that's higher
than national average yes per occupation
so i just think
there's a tricky balance
there's a tricky balance in
in art um
so yeah of course
like it's it's a necessary thing the
fragility of it all
but um
yeah i wonder because i'm extremely
self-critical and i sometimes ask myself
the question
i've romanticized it or rather
i've learned to be
for it to be productive to channel into
productivity
but i i wonder
if there's better ways to do that and i
also wonder if it's eventually the thing
that destroys me like if long-term right
if it's a healthy thing it might be
useful
when you're in sort of
actively
fighting the battles of the day the for
me it's engineering challenges and all
that kind of stuff right but then when
you're sitting back
and enjoying life
with family and so on is that going to
be like do you need to find that
self-love like ability to kind of
um silence the voice of criticism in
your head you know what i i really
there's a you're making a good point and
i think
that the middle ground
is you need
you need self-doubt
to push you to be better
i i do believe that like
for instance if i if i believed
i've had my like when you're like is
there a song on there that you think is
genius if i think i've written a genius
song ever i think i'd probably stop
i think i'd be like you know what
did it i wrote um
uh what's that perfect song
uh
imagine imagine yet okay if i'd written
imagine i'd probably be like
that's it did it all right perfect song
has been written that's the best thing
i'll ever do yeah
so the fact that that there is
like
self-criticism and criticism outside i
think is necessary 100 100 for sure it
pushes you it pushes you it pushes you
it's just finding
the right middle ground for that young
aspiring artist to also not feel
squashed and to be heard
and to love just not even to feel squash
just to love themself
so that when they're in the room playing
the song
they'll believe it because
they believe themselves they love
themselves enough that they believe it
and then they'll do a great and then the
song will come out great and they'll do
a great performance
you